the CDA stands for Christian democratic apple apple
no apple
and the leader of that party is Henry pied Wal
tadaa he is 41
years and is also called a professor by colleagues
called bontal
because he can't finish talking
about the books he reads
and colorful ball loves to play the organ
he does that quite well
but what does the CDA actually want
the CDA considers the family very important
and wants vulnerable people to be taken care of
and they also think that the government
should not interfere with everything
continue The party wants to chase the wolf away from the Netherlands
and help farmers to slowly become more sustainable
Henri finds these points very important
for children
we need to invest more in families
so we need more money
to supporting families
for example through child benefit
I think we should also continue to invest
in improving the environment
because we have 1 climate problem
we need more energy savings
I want children with 1 disability
even
can often participate in support as ordinary children